SIMU LIU
One of the best things about the MCU
is getting to see your
favorite characters team up.
AWKWAFINA
Totally! Like Ant-Man and the Wasp,
or Iron Man and War Machine,
or Rocket and Groot!
Today we're going
to play a rapid-fire game...
...featuring Marvel's
newest superhero, Shang-Chi. You ready?
SIMU LIU
Let's go!
AWKWAFINA
Aliens are invading New York.
SIMU LIU
I'm gonna go with Captain Marvel.
AWKWAFINA
Who does he grab a slice with?
SIMU LIU
Uh, Tony Stark!
AWKWAFINA
Busting up an enemy bunker together with?
SIMU LIU
Hulk.
AWKWAFINA
Karaoke night! Who's he harmonizing with?
SIMU LIU
You!
KATY and SHANG-CHI
[Singing] Over, sideways, and under...
AWKWAFINA
Going up against Thanos!
Who would he want
to be next to him?
SIMU LIU
Iron Man.
AWKWAFINA
You're running late to a friend's party,
who would you call to give
you a lift to get there on time?
SIMU LIU
You.
KATY
We make a good team.
AWKWAFINA
Alright, last one!
Joy-riding through
San Francisco in a sweet new ride...
KATY
I'm driving!
AWKWAFINA
...you borrowed from someone
way nicer than you?
SIMU LIU
Uh, borrowed?
KATY
Get in. I'll go slow.
SHANG-CHI
Right! Go right!
AWKWAFINA
Don't miss the MCU's newest hero
and his BFF Katy...